Sometimes in the political analysis space,
we over analyze obvious things.
And then other times were under exposing major
stories.
And then sometimes it's sort of both at once.
And that's the case here.
A top Trump adviser went on TV yesterday and
three times refused to deny that the Trump
administration was or would accept was accepting
or would accept foreign campaign assistance
and opposition research on Joe Biden and then
ultimately ended up sort of saying, well,
we're not accepting it right now without actually
saying we would not accept it.
This is both a major story that should be
110 percent exposed, but it's also a completely
obvious position of the campaign that requires
no analysis, because it is exactly what Donald
Trump has been saying for months or years
that he would do so.
Let's take a look.
Here is Jason Miller.
Trump campaign adviser.
We've seen clips of him before.
Wacky guy.
Interviewed by Chris Wallace on Fox News Sunday
yesterday.
And this is the first attempt from Chris Wallace
asking, has the Trump campaign received information
from foreign
groups or nationals on Joe Biden or Joe Biden's
family?
Will you accept it if it were to be offered?
This is the first shot at getting an answer
to the question.
Can you state flatly that neither the Trump
administration nor the Trump campaign has
received any information from foreign groups,
foreign nationals, about either Joe Biden
or his family?
And can you state the fault flatly that neither
the administration nor the campaign will accept
foreign assistance?
Chris?
That's a silly question.
I mean, the folks who have actually taken
foreign assistance where the Clinton campaign
four years ago, I mean, the entire shady dossier
they put together was from a British spy.
No, we're gonna go and beat Joe Biden fair
and square here.
Absolutely.
But I think you should have asked the same
question to numerous prospective running mates
and Senator Duckworth and Karen Bass, because
just as we saw four years ago, it was the
Democrats who took foreign assistance.
So look at the specifics of what Jason Miller
says.
It's a silly question.
Well, that's not a denial.
It was Democrats who did that.
That's not a denial.
We're going to beat Joe Biden fair and square.
Trump has already said he considers at least
checking out for an opposition research as
being okay.
So therefore, in their mind, it's arguably
fair and square to do exactly what Chris Wallace
is asking about.
So Chris Wallace tries again.
Here's a second time.
But can you flatly state that the Trump campaign
and the administration will not accept foreign
assistance?
That's gone.
Chris, I said that's absolutely silly question.
We're gonna go and win this race fair and
square, asking the Democrats for an answer.
It's like, again, not a denial.
This isn't that tough, right.
Jason Miller says for a second time.
That's a silly question.
We're going to win fair and square.
Trump believes it is fair to win with foreign
opposition research.
So Chris Wallace is right to be skeptical
of the way that Jason Miller is answering
these questions.
Let's now back up a few seconds and then we're
going to hear the third attempt and the third
sort of nonanswer.
We're going to go and win this race fair and
square, asking the Democrats for an answer
in sight.
And so yes or no question, Jason.
Chris, there is no foreign assistance is happening
in this campaign by would ask you to make
sure the Democrats are going to do what they
tried to pull four years ago, because that's
exactly they're going to try to find every
possible way to cheat and steal this election.
One hundred percent.
There is no foreign assistance that's happening
now again.
That's not a denial that they would accept
it.
And of course, this is laying the groundwork
for if later it's discovered that the Trump
campaign did accept foreign opposition research
or info they can hide behind.
Look.
Miller said that at the time they hadn't received
any.
And maybe at the time that was true and they
could argue a technicality.
But this this really is a big deal.
But it's also not shocking in that Donald
Trump admits this.
Donald Trump in that infamous interview with
ABC's George Stephanopoulos about a year ago,
I think it was might have been was it May
of twenty nine to I don't even remember when
it was, but roughly in the last year or 15
months.
Donald Trump said to George Stephanopoulos,
Yeah.
I would look at stuff from Russia.
I would
look at stuff from China.
Sure.
Why not?
So Jason Miller can't really say no because
Trump has already said yes publicly.
That's the crazy part of it.
His answer to can you categorically and definitively
say that you won't accept foreign help is
it's not happening right now.
And it's a silly question.
Not particularly convincing.
Now, also, there is this focus from them on
Democrats doing it.
That's a new talking point.
You heard it used there by Jason Miller, asked
about what the Trump campaign did is or will
do, saying, well, it's Democrats who actually
did it.
You know, Christopher Steele, the dossier,
Bubba Bubba.
Democrats don't need foreign assistance for
information on Donald Trump.
Democrats don't even need really domestic
assistance because Trump has done it all.
Anything and everything you can imagine in
the light of day.
And that's why I'm sort of both
optimistic and preemptively depressed.
If we can't beat Trump, given what he's done
in the last three and a half years, in a sense,
the country deserves Trump for another four
years.
I mean, I don't I don't know how to say it
if Trump cheats to win.
Right.
If the will of the people actually is for
Trump to be defeated and Trump cheats to win.
That's different.
But if in a fair and square election, this
guy gets reelected, unbalance tens of millions
of us, of course, don't agree with it.
But on balance, don't we deserve another four
years if after all this, we don't remove the
guy something I've been thinking about,